make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are picking up with Captain
America by Tallahassee codes I think
this is probably one of the best comics
that nobody's reading and it's kind of
supporting because like admit like okay
so here's my stance like secret Empire
was the best Captain America story ever
told and I don't care what anybody says
like there's a lot of naysayers out
there don't care like I loved captain
like I loved to secret him pilot it was
a nothing it was amazingly written it
was amazingly drawn like I absolutely
like I adore that story I will say
that's 25 years of reading comics and
and with the exception of spider-man
Clone Saga I've never seen people get so
up in arms about a single story arc
before but nonetheless one of the big
things atomic etana ha psychos does is
he actually draws on secret Empire
pretty heavily here in the sense that
the way these kind of pop off in the
beginning is you basically have like
these Hydra agents really what's left of
Hydra under secret Empire but what's
basically going on here is that after
secret Empire ended and Hydra was
toppled there's still remnants across
the world like there's still remnants of
different places all over the place
those who just kind of refused to let
the idea go that hey look like Hydra is
still here there's no way that happening
what is it happening here is we
basically meet with a girl named Alexa
now she will be explained once we get
later on in the story so I'm not gonna
spoil anything here but it's kind of a
cool thing because where this Hydra cell
is basically making its escape they're
suddenly met by the arrival of a woman
in black who essentially destroys them
all and when Alexa you know kind of gets
out the two of them start talking we end
up realizing that like the two of them
are working together but this woman in
black is Selene now this was actually
really cool and it really really caught
me by surprise because Selene is largely
an x-men villain so so in Marvel College
those guys who were new or those guys
who are who are not familiar with saline
in Marvel Comics you've got different
types of mutes right and we've talked
about this in previous videos but you've
got different types of mutants you've
got like proto proto mutants and then
you've got like you know traditional
mutants like the x-men Cyclops Wolverine
professor x-men
magneto and then you have what are
called externals and externals are
mutants who are legitimately immortal
what does this mean well it means that
like they can they can be killed through
physical means right like you can chop
their heads off or something along those
lines but if they're never injured if
they're if they're never attacked if
they're never beheaded or something like
that
then they'll live forever because
they're immune to aging they're immune
to to all diseases all those different
things that exists that differ between
Selene and a lot of the other externals
who were out there it's Turtles like
Gideon or somebody like that is Selene
has to basically siphon off life energy
in order to keep herself youthful
so she's an external but with kind of a
caveat so as she's sort of unique among
the various externals who exist out
there but in this instance she's
essentially working directly alongside
Alexa now we didn't initially know why
and FICO again we'll sort of figure this
out but what it does is it shifts over
to Captain America and what Captain
America is basically dealing with here
is kind of like this this Hydra protest
that was going on and then was met by
the arrival of water essentially like an
army of nukes
now nuke is a guy by the name of Frank
Simpson these are all essentially like
clones of him it seems but nuke was a
character who was part of weapons Plus
right like that was whole Grant
Morrison's new x-men that huge expansion
on the Weapon X project and it is one of
these things where basically what he
established was that Captain America was
weapon one and then after Captain
America was believed to have been dead
you had weapons two through ten ten of
course being Weapon X and then you had a
few after Weapon X of course Deadpool
phantom X has Stepford cuckoos different
things like that but the idea of nuke
was to kind of create a Captain America
with a modified concept but he was
essentially bonded with like cybernetic
implants and then given like these red
white and blue pills and the different
pills would have different effects it
would amp him up where they would keep a
neutral or they would bring him down but
the idea is that Frank Simpsons kind of
a guy who came out of the war and then
just never left the war and so whenever
you see him going on his rampages he'll
talk about like all they got our boys
you know and everything like that and
sort of losing his mind but with all
these different versions here what
they're doing is as soon as Captain
America shows up where you would think
they would side with Captain America
because of the fact that it's Captain
America they remember him as Captain
America from secret Empire and so the
result is that where he is back to being
a normal good guy we're like the actual
Captain America returned Frank Simpson
all these guys turned their guns on him
and go to attack him and the reason why
is because seeing him as basically you
know kind of the the Hydra cap is they
in turn basically say like you sold our
boys out like you sold our guys out when
you took power when you basically killed
like the president United States all
these different things you sold our guys
out and and so many of our soldiers were
killed because of you and it's kind of a
crazy scenario here because these guys
are dealt with pretty fast you know
between Captain America Bucky Barnes
Sharon Carter things are wrapped up
pretty quickly but then you have the
introduction of Thunderbolt Ross and
Ross basically comes in and tells Sharon
Carter like look you don't really work
for shield me more at least Sharon
Carter sessions work for shield anymore
his idea is but you'll always be agent
13 I have a mission for you you need to
come with me we're basically gonna
investigate the source of all these
different nukes or whatever Captain
America here you can't come along and
under normal circumstances Captain
America would be there but
one of the big ramifications of things
that came out of secret Empire America
does not trust Captain America and it's
really it's a really really cool concept
there's still fallout from secret Empire
the Captain America's not viewed the
same way that he used to be that things
have changed forever because of the
events of secret Empire and it was kind
of a cool scenario here because again
things sort of turned on their head and
what you end up having going on here is
like Selene and her guys basically you
know kind of marshalling forces or the
very least showing some representation
in Russia you have Captain America who
basically goes to Sharon Carter and is
like look I essentially want you to keep
tabs and like let me know what's going
on in terms of the information you get
and she of course says that's not
something that I can do I can't just
hand information over like that things
aren't the way they used to be anymore
really kind of creating this bit of a
rift of sorts and it's one of the things
that on Ahoskie Coates uses when he has
Captain America kind of asking this
question does anybody trust me anymore
it's a cool thing and so what Captain
America is really kind of done here is
kind of create his own end run Secret
Avengers and what I mean by that is is
you know during the events of Civil War
when you had like Iron Man's Avengers
team public defenders team that was
fighting on behalf of shield and the
federal government and registration you
had Captain America underground with his
Secret Avengers it's really kind of
where that name came from the difference
here is that they're not gonna have a
huge role and what Captain America is
doing but it's basically kind of
tallahassee Coates putting the offerees
on the table and say somewhere along the
line this will essentially be a position
that's out there something that can be
used now this is one of the really cool
things that comes out of this it's
Captain America working alongside as
sort of Secret Avengers begins to go on
the same mission that Sharon Carter is
but by a different means he's
investigating using the own information
that he gets and he hasn't been this
small town and he's up talking to this
guy named Joe and one of the things Joe
basically says is the country's not
really better off after secret Empire
than it was during secret Empire under
the rule of Hydra as as cruel as it was
and as crappy as it was for a lot of
people that Hydra fix the school systems
that Hydra got rid of drugs that
everybody had healthcare the
unemployment rate was astronomically low
the country was actually better because
of Hydra and what basically ended up
happening is it was like the superhero
community the you know essentially sat
down and said yes we know things are
better under Hydra but like they're bad
guys though so like we're gonna topple
them and then we're gonna send you right
back to the cesspool you were in before
and then like we can try to make it
better which didn't happen that was one
of the great things about secret Empire
is it was really kind of Hydra cat
coming along and basically saying hey
look America you had your chance I'll do
it by force and like he did and it
worked it's kind of interesting here
because when Captain America sort of
goes on this on this discussion and he
sort of has this kind of like inner
monologue with himself is really kind of
a question of like is the country
actually better off and it's one of
those things because what it does is it
throws Captain America's entire
existence into question if nobody trusts
Captain America if Captain America is
essentially retrained to a country
that's as bad as it ever was and then on
some level has to acknowledge there were
at least some things that Hydra did
right then like of what use is Captain
America what purpose does he serve the
value of Captain America is essentially
gone now as one of these things where if
the value of Captain America as a symbol
of American freedom is gone people don't
trust him do people even trust their own
country do they even trust themselves
these are a lot of the introspective
questions that Captain America is asking
and so of course they end up locating
this factory and basically you know
finding out that Ezekiel Stane the son
of Obadiah Stane is the one that's like
mass producing all these versions of
nuke but we don't really know what the
end goal is here it's just this is one
part of a much larger group is
essentially going through like all these
crazy schemes all these crazy these
crazy goals but it's one of the cool
things because we'll actually find out
how America is perceived in relation to
like this organization as a whole but as
we as we kind of go through this is sort
of a cool scenario because where they go
through and they basically you know
defeat all these different guys you know
and take all these different people out
and so on and so forth we end up having
Sharon Carter met directly with the
arrival of Selene herself and that's
kind of a dangerous thing because
remember Sharon Carter doesn't really
have any powers to speak up she's a
normal person and so where she's
essentially taken by Selene and then
brought to a LexA but literally alexis
starts taunting Sharon Carter and says
you don't know who I am I don't know how
you don't know who I am or I guess
there's no reason for you to let me tell
you exactly who I am what she says here
is my name is Alexa Lucan now this is a
very very big deal this hearkens all the
way back to Ed Brubaker 's run which I
would consider to be like the second
best Captain America story ever and what
ended up happening here is there was a
guy named Alexander Lucan and Alexander
Luthor was actually a guy who ended up
having his body shared with the Red
Skull after everything went south with
red skulls Cosmic Cube so essentially
like Red Skull was walking around in the
body of Alexander Lucan for quite some
time but Alexander Lucan red skull dr.
Fausta's they're the ones who engineered
the original assassination of Captain
America after the events of Civil War
and so with that happening like Sharon
Carter begins to realize what's going on
that this is a woman who is somehow in
relation to Alexander Lucan Alexander
Lucan being the person that was one of
the members who basically got Sharon to
kill
in America that's one of the things to
remember is that during the
assassination of Captain America that
Sharon Carter was basically brainwashed
by dr. Fosters and so when Captain
America was being transported to the
courthouse dead during the process he
was shot in the shoulder by crossbones
though all everybody was running and
screaming and everybody was panicking
Sharon Carter ran up on him and shot him
in the stomach
and that's basically what killed Captain
America and so when she ended up
realizing what was done and suddenly was
oh my god I killed Captain America you
know once the brainwashing wore off
there's a couple other really really
cool points to sort of come out of this
is that when Alexis talking to Sharon
what she basically says is like
America's ripe for the picking it's
politically divided in every conceivable
way and she says the Allies that we
needed to achieve our goal they're
everywhere like they're all over the
place there were soldiers who fought
against Hydra they come back and now
they're considered outcasts now the
country's broken and shattered and it's
so easy to control a government like
that now of course this also basically
results in Captain America running an
attack master and it's kind of worth
mentioning here it's kind of a cool
little discussion a cool little fight
that goes on here granted you know
Captain America fighting against
taskmaster is no simple thing Captain
America doesn't just walk all over
taskmaster and the reason why is because
remember taskmaster mimics basically
he's able to like adapt his fighting
style to the person that he's fighting
not only that once he memorizes a
fighting style he never loses it and
it's one of the things that Captain
America basically hits on here that
while he's fighting taskmaster he's
fighting like the fighting styles of
iron fist and the fighting styles of
like Luke Cage the style of anybody
who's ever faced off against him
including Captain America himself and so
it's like fighting an army of people all
at the same time and taskmaster actually
gets the upper hand on capp because of
the fact that taskmaster fights based on
the style that he's experienced before
his limitation is that he doesn't really
know how to adapt to his style that he
hasn't faced before at least he can but
it takes some time and so because of
that Captain America is a kept America
stance is beat fast be Swift and use a
style of taskmasters not familiar with
and that's exactly what he does the two
of them basically face off and Captain
America starts using like street
fighting tactics and when he does like
he's able to eventually overcome
taskmaster and basically went but the
caveat to this is that if they fight
again taskmaster will be used to the way
that Captain America fights release his
version of them and so it's a cool
little concept a cool way to sort of
overcome and a way to basically win but
of course when Captain America shows up
and starts facing off against like
Celine or at least intends to face off
against Celine and Alexa it's kind of a
cool little moment when Captain America
like recognizes who Saleem is and
basically says like there's like two
things like you
do hear the first thing is to get you
know Sharon Carter out of harm's way and
the second thing is to pray because
Celine having been around for 10,000
years is a prodigiously and if she faces
off against Captain America all she has
to do is get her hands on it and as soon
as that happens Captain America is done
for it but of course once all this
happens the portal opens and Selena and
Alexa basically leave because the
missions been accomplished the whole
base is behind them taking Sharon Carter
has been accomplished and the reason why
is because all they needed was a sample
in order to basically travel to this
rejuvenation pod and to bring back
Alexander Lucan but that's one of the
funny things is for the most part
Alexa's not fully aware of what's going
on here for her it's Alexander Lucan for
Alexander Lucan it's the Red Skull and
that's basically what's happened here is
the red skulls been resurrected and so
it's kind of a cool little moment again
it's pretty awesome to kind of see this
unfold but when the two of them cousins
start going back and forth and they sort
of start having this discussion and
talking about things one of the things
Alexa does when she talked about
Alexander like here's all the things
that you've missed here's what's gone on
she talked about secret Empire all that
kind of stuff but she says like our
ability to basically implement control
of the governments like take over
everything it's in motion like we can
pull this off because America's screwed
up in America's fractured that there's
one section of America that wants to go
back to the way things were under Hydra
because it was easier because the
country was in a lot of ways better off
but freedom was essentially restricted
to an almost non-existent state then
there are others who basically say yes
the country sucks now but at least we
have freedom hurray for that hopefully
you can pay the bills and so it's one of
these cool little things because she's
kind of like we have the chance to
conquer everything like we literally
have the chance to make our move and
it's one of the one of the big questions
this kind of asked here is what do we do
about Captain America and that's when
she basically makes the case and she
says look you don't have to kill Captain
America because nobody believes in him
anymore
nobody cares about him anymore he's a
guy who's reminiscent of an age in the
United States when Hydra conquered the
conquerer the country and people just
want to kind of put their head in the
sand and pretend like that never
happened and by doing that basically
turned their back on Captain America no
one trusts him anymore because when they
look at him they see Hydra cap and so
because of that like you can kill Steve
Rogers if you want to but like Captain
America is basically dead there is no
more Captain America now of course we
also end up finding out that Thunderbolt
Ross has essentially been assassinated
and it's kind of a cool little thing
because when that happens you have Nick
Fury who basically returns who's kind of
wrought out ever since shield went belly
up and the whole point of Nick Fury
being here is to ask the question who
was it they kill Thunderbolt Ross and
then interrogate Captain America to see
if it was him
really
hitting home at the idea that like
nobody trusts Captain America anymore
because of the aftermath of secret
Empire it's awesome I absolutely love it
like I feel like this is like one of the
best stories that nobody's reading I
love this idea but with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end if you are new here - comments
explained make sure you guys at the sub
button to become part of the robb core
if you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and I will catch you all
later purse